[Music]
this headline confused me when i first
read it maybe you'll know exactly what
it means when i say it but
getting a haircut is the only way to see
live music in the netherlands what
what
getting a why only way to see live music
in the netherlands
is get your fade on
what the [ __ ] maybe it's the machine
buzzing oh is it amsterdam
um
this guy gets a f for english
yeah it's amsterdam yeah so um what that
means is that it's basically uh a way
for them to fight back to the mandates
because i knew it was kobe related
hair salons are allowed to operate but
concert halls can't oh so
so they're holding concerts in barber
shops
well almost they're calling concerts
barbershops barbers to the [ __ ] live
concerts
wow which is a smarter idea
[Laughter]
it's three-person concerts
so what they did is they turned
huge concert halls into basically little
barber shops where
everyone who's watching the concert is
really just waiting to get their haircut
that's smart that's [ __ ] hilarious
that's their way of fighting back double
standard which is that's smart but
that's also ridiculous yeah well wait
till you see it then
i wonder how they did it here you go
whoa wow
oh sorry yeah that is so smart
it's a it's a classical concert too i
thought it would be like so [ __ ] punk
rock and it would be like um
like a rock show i didn't picture a
[ __ ] orchestra yeah so there's two
people getting their hair done on the
stage in front of the orchestra
everybody else who's watching it is just
waiting to return that's pretty smart
we're living in are they really getting
a real haircut we're really in an
alternate that i don't know because it's
like a bald guy
damn that's smart man this ain't even
this is another one of those cases where
betty white's like yeah peace out yeah
like what the [ __ ] is this like this is
something like you know like hunger
games oh yeah look at some other reality
like oh yeah they're like that's how
they're doing it because like look at
this guy do you think he needs
to get a razor bro you just clean but
what's weirder though the
the rules that don't make sense or the
people that are just trying to figure
out how to navigate the rules i love the
people that are navigating that's the
best part about it right but then the
rules are [ __ ] ridiculous i mean the
rules
have been ridiculous for a long time i
know right haven't really looked at like
we haven't really looked at the rules
like oh the rules have been but they're
ridiculous they're now no we just take
it to the next level ridiculous but if
you really think about it for a while
like damn we've been on some ridiculous
ass rules for a [ __ ] while have you
guys met anyone yet that absolutely
believes in all the rules and like
fights for them because i have met i
don't even mean i don't even know i see
them online yeah i seen them online but
like what the [ __ ]
i don't know anyone dude like
maybe maybe i would say in april 2020 or
more like in the very first months right
people are on high alert they didn't
know
that makes sense
but then like now
i don't know anyone that's like you have
to [ __ ] do this no we all know it's
kind of ridiculous we all know like you
put a mask on to go in the restaurant
but then when you sit down you're no
mask on don't mean that's pretty what
the [ __ ] that's ridiculous yeah so
that's that's a lot of people in that
restaurant i'm not going to that
restaurant yes sam's like oh that
restaurant's a little too packed all
right no [ __ ] want that one so it
kind of is like a statement they're
trying to make but also their biggest
thing too was also saying that like the
seats in a concert hall are just as
situated as like a hair salon because
they're their main things they want
people walking around moving around it's
like yeah you're already in seats that
don't move it's the same idea so they
just really wanted to make that
statement which is cool because i
respect that like we nobody's doing that
[ __ ] out here making statements this
clear you know they're all classy and
[ __ ] yeah organized orchestra everybody
agrees with the idea at the same time
they execute it pretty much i mean
amsterdam
too here you just go yeah here you could
just go see bts
yeah that is yeah you can just go to the
concerts like that's on you if you catch
this shit's on you it is pretty cool to
see how other countries kind of handle
their issues and like what uh different
issues they that they all have to go
through but it is kind of crazy too to
think about like we are in
for first time ever in our lives where
we have a [ __ ] global pendant like
this is a crazy [ __ ] situation didn't
sweden or finland just be like [ __ ]
heard immunity and they've been open and
they've been like normal yeah they were
they did it out there yeah
yeah they they they never locked down so
even flights coming in from like i don't
know about that no i heard it they were
good at first and then i heard it hit
them hard afterwards oh but i heard the
[ __ ] again because i'll hear say but
i heard japan got like no cases for some
[ __ ] reason japan's like we're good
yeah they're not there's no mandate a
vaccine are people allowed to go there
it's probably green tea uh there's a
mandatory quarantine it's a mandatory
quarantine but when the people there
they're like it's pretty you can go
there now but you gotta wait remarkably
like almost nothing because they already
have masks because they already wear
masks
and someone said something about seaweed
bro it has something to do with the
yakuza thank you very much
japanese mob is like kobe i will [ __ ]
sounds up more authentic that i was
ready for yeah
yeah the rules are crazy because like
you could be at the mall right you're
like this and then like the security is
like hey put a mask on and you're like
oh i'm so sorry i didn't know so you can
literally walk down the mall no mask on
empty cans as long as you have a drink
rules are ridiculous like like all of a
sudden all these states we can smoke
weeded right
yeah
what was the difference we could smoke
weed and what the [ __ ] like growing up
it was like
you're going to jump for that weed
growing up it was like you were a
crackhead my mom's like i'll try some
weed i'm like now you'll try weak
because the government said you can
smoke weed yeah you beat my ass for
smoking weed what was that
yeah it's just a consideration of
weirdness like yeah [ __ ]
right it's it is really weird it gets me
back to that book i read called uh
sapiens where
we're supposed to read it as a group and
break down this damn book
it's just stories we just stories we
choose to follow that's all there's no
nothing's real yeah all that stuff is
just what we decide rules aren't real
countries race is not real it's just
a story that we chose to like to agree
upon yeah and the reality categories you
said history like [ __ ] want to
stand in history like that shit's fluid
too that's not real like don't stay on
history because
that's not real that's just a perception
his story okay
what i'm saying like at all it's so
fluid what's true is could be
whatever it could be different tomorrow
but it freaks people out right because
like we all need to make sense of
reality we all need to define what
things are
we need we need to know or else the
uncertainty makes people extremely
afraid anarchy yeah so some people will
give up freedom
of you know liberty and belief and
whatever
as long as they feel secure and safe and
i feel like this is a great
experiment like a lot of people are just
being like yeah yeah just [ __ ] take
the vaccine shut up already like yeah
what like whatever whatever who cares
about your freedoms and i'm just like
uh
why do you have to be labeled like this
crazy trump supporter when you just want
to question you know hey where did this
vaccine come from you just want more
info or like eight like what are the
information like and then you gotta
question like the sources and you're
just like
and also you gotta question the motive
of the governing comedians like are you
guys infiltrated by
corruption like who knows everyone's
infiltrating everybody
even questioning that now is like you're
a crazy person that's what's really sad
is like
you asking something about government
rules is way more demonizing than asking
is jesus real in church exactly first of
all we are in a christian country that
you're just like
yeah have we thought about the paper
thinness of this story yet no no one but
we're gonna go die for that [ __ ] yeah
someone gonna die for that [ __ ] and then
i'm like
i get it yeah question a lot of stuff
but like can we do can we politicize
something other than this vaccine
everyone pretending like they already
don't got vaccines in them like yeah
everyone [ __ ] have a problem with
like you already got vaccines in your
uterus that's who's like snorkel
i'm not gonna let you put a vaccine in
me [ __ ]
i don't put poison in my body it's like
also one thing doesn't necessitate
another it's like this vaccine is our
freedom like god
let's just choose something else all
right it's like let's just say whatever
else a gun whatever seat belts seat
belts thank you seat belt i just don't
want to be politicized
i am trump supporter like why do we have
to politicize let's politicize something
else that will
[ __ ] get us through some [ __ ] but the
rules are like are they really to help
people
is it because you guys are just too lazy
and you don't know what to do like
motives i want to know motives right
also like even like the vaccine and all
these things like it's like big pharma
are you trying to make money are you
really like do you really care about the
american people like it's it's confusing
and there's too many things so i think
it's easier for people to just go just
follow the [ __ ] rules and let's get
over with this so we could get on with
our lives
i think that's what happens a lot and
even like because you you're working on
set a lot with now this new man native
having all these like covet officers
that are just freestyling random ass
rules all the time there's that but
there's also someone but guess what
someone gets it always something and
then that [ __ ] locks down
now now you're talking about money now
you're back to money right
you lock down the set now you loosen
hundreds of thousands of dollars a day
if not millions and now you're like now
you're the [ __ ] that just stopped
[ __ ] you know i'm saying so mm-hmm
everything comes out if you catch cover
you can't tell anybody
i mean coke was at a place where people
are like very [ __ ]
i'm healthy
that's also randomly weird though
because like you catch cover you don't
tell anybody and then that's weird but
then there's some people who have covet
but they don't know
so they're you're in essence doing the
same objective thing as somebody else
you know but because because you like i
don't know maybe had choice it's like
you're wrong so same thing vaccinated
unvaccinated getting the booster not
getting the booster getting covered not
getting it we're still in the same gray
area cesspool of everything and all of
it exists every variable is present and
we're all trying to figure it out dude i
almost choked the [ __ ] out of my friend
because i was uh i picked his ass up
right and we're driving
and about 30 minutes into the car ride
he goes joe i had kovid and i'm like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you waited to
[ __ ] say that to the card he goes
yeah had
half had it yesterday holy [ __ ] and i
was like i was like we're like what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] right well first
off
when was this
uh no no this was months ago many many
months you're okay right under five days
ago right so i'm driving and i'm like
you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] why did you
wait till now to tell me because if i
told you you wouldn't have picked me up
god damn it i was desperate i needed to
go out we need to hike and i'm like
you selfish son of a [ __ ] you [ __ ]
infect me with cohen i'm about to go to
[ __ ] hawaii you're gonna pay for
those goddamn tickets for me you [ __ ]
oh yeah cause if i if i wasn't if i
didn't have plans he couldn't just go
hike himself he was lonely people it's
for his mental health send that ass
mental health above all
just go hike and just meditate or some
[ __ ] friends dude no mental health
obviously
you know he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] but i love
his ass right but he's like you don't
understand being alone for those long
days i was quarantining i was like how
many [ __ ] days did you weigh i think
10 i think i don't know i lost count of
days and i'm all like you're supposed to
weigh 14 you [ __ ] face but the cdc says
10 now
you [ __ ] waited i was about to choke
the [ __ ] out of him and get covered from
[ __ ] breaking that six foot rule at
least he waited ten days though in a car
in a car in a [ __ ] car
and my girlfriend was in the car she's
international so how the [ __ ] is she
gonna go back
if she gets covered right so then piece
of [ __ ] i had a flight to hawaii i had a
flight to hawaii in uh in like in five
days and i'm like you [ __ ] face you know
we have to take a test and do all this
[ __ ] before we travel right i'm like
you're gonna ruin my [ __ ] vacation on
top of that all this [ __ ] and he
goes oh but then like i'm gonna join you
in hawaii so like if i can't go that
means you can't go and i'm like no if
you [ __ ] [ __ ] there's more
i'm like there's more days that you had
quarantined you're gonna test [ __ ]
negative
well i'm positive
and he's like oh [ __ ] and i was like oh
son of a [ __ ] you [ __ ] me so bad but
then i tested every [ __ ] day and i
was clear and he was see i told you i
was okay wow did you apologize
no no no that's what you apologized
you should have apologized joe and then
you could you could have got it just
been like not for you
and then that's bad too that's true
[Music]
[Music]
you